[Music]
me
no it's not Ocean's 14. well you're
you're in the know but fans love to see
the longtime Pals reunite then I rush it
felt like I was good I liked it Brad and
George spotted on the set of their next
movie for Apple TV plus I literally see
this this old gray-haired guy and it's
like oh that's me or was it George's
latest co-star and the salt and pepper
facial hair that's looking pretty
familiar both actors Don flat coats and
gray pants while filming in the Big
Apple yeah we'd call each other just
before we leave the training moment
comes after Brad's painful confession to
vote who are the most handsome men in
the world past and present
if I was going to name someone present
well I got to name that George Clooney I
would guess it's me
this thing about me because usually I'm
always taking him out and he's always
taking me out and this time I'm going to
go the other way just this once George
that one's for you yeah they're behind
the scenes pranks are kind of legendary
the act of not pulling a prank that was
the problem
the fact that he did not pull a prank
he's notorious for pranks he'll write
pranks out for a year well once I heard
that he was checking his room every
night then I just stayed home I did a
lot of reading
I bet we could find a picture of you in
there too ask for their latest flick
it's not another casino Heist but sounds
like a pretty fun Dynamics on the way
Apple says the Thriller follows two lone
fixers who are assigned to the same job
and here's the real question do we think
their former co-star can tell whose
beard is whose
[Music]
wait
[Applause]
wow
back to George and Brad sadly no details
on a release date for their next big
screen outing but in the meantime fans
can have fun picturing their latest
round of onset hygiene That's it man
we're just gonna die so let's like let's
have some fun before before we go out
[Music]